[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George camel ramsy
personality host of The George camel
show very popular on YouTube is my
co-host today the phone number Isle
88255 225 very important day for Mr
George camel and all of us here at
Ramsey in that this is the last day you
can get the deal on his brand new book
Breaking Free from broke because
tomorrow is launch day woo here we go
baby it's here game on yeah and
tomorrow's the Super Bowl and today is
the warm-up if you guys want the deal
though this is your Super Bowl because
the book Breaking Free from broke the
Ultimate Guide to more money and less
stress absolutely incredible new book
comes out tomorrow what that means for
you if you're listening and hear this
before Tuesday the 16th uh up until
midnight on uh the 15th you can get the
book and a whole bunch of goodies oh
yeah you get instant access to my talk
show me the money it's a video talk we
have an online private event happening
next week with a Q&A and this is the big
one the enhanced audiobook you get
completely for free with all the sound
design and custom music and it's the
team did an amazing job it's a very cool
audio book very cool and that's totally
free when you pre-order the hard cover
and of course the ebook as well for you
digital readers out there and no matter
when you buy the book you also get three
months of every dollar premium so I
wanted people to have an actionable plan
when they walk away and not just huh
good book I want you to actually go live
out the principles and take control of
your money and choose hope instead of
cynicism this year as we head into an
election Dave oh that's hard to do in
that in that in that setting but anyway
anyway so the deal is that you have done
some in-depth detailed research on the
scams and schemes of the people that
want to take your money from you boys
and girls out there and George exposes
the mythology and and the villains in
The Marketplace absolutely this the
first two-thirds of the book unpacks The
System designed to keep you broke and I
talk about credit scores and credit
cards which I believe are the gateway
drug into all the other types of debt I
cover car loans and uh suud loans and
mortgage traps and investing traps and
marketing and consumerism which just
exacerbates the whole problem and I
think once you get through of that
you're going to want to take a shower
you're going to have enough ick that you
go okay I need to opt out of this I do
need to break free from this kind of
broke it's I call them chains cuz I
think most Americans they're they work
too hard to feel this broke they're
feeling the chains of payments in this
world they feel like they're on the
hamster in the wheel rat in the Maze an
Uber ride from hell and they just want
something different and I think this
book is going to help you live counter
culturally and give you hope that you
can break free from those chains and
have freedom with your money so you'll
get the knowledge you'll get the
confidence to break free and uh all of
the evidence is there with great detail
and you you guys that are a little bit
nerdy and like the research uh George is
a consumer Advocate at heart and he
can't resist uh digging up the dirt and
proving to you how you're being screwed
there's 130 sources in this book it was
exhausting to do all the research but I
had to prove it not just my opinion and
our experience of you know you doing the
show for 30 years but actual data from
you know the Federal Reserve and from
MIT proving our plan works so brand new
book out on the 16th of January if you
hear this before then up until midnight
on the 15th you can get the new book
Breaking Free from broke and instant
access to Georgia's newest talk show me
the money exclusive access to an online
private event next week uh a Q&A with
George the enhanced audio book and so
what we decided to do was take all of
our audio books from this point forward
and put a little Jazz to them make them
a little better make them make them a
little little sound effects some
Sounders coming in and out rather than
just us reading the book which I was the
guinea pig for this yeah you were you're
the first one out I don't know if we're
going to want to be called a guinea pig
or not but yeah but anyway you were the
first one you were a Pioneer George well
it's because you know I've hosted our
podcast borrowed future the fine print
and I've always loved that kind of
narrative storytelling style that has
some of those elements in it and I even
did some custom music Dave the intro and
outro for each chapter is actually my my
playing even James producer James got in
there he played one of them so that's a
little Easter egg for you guys oh there
you go I unless you hated the music in
which case it wasn't me Dave I well and
until I see the bill for the royalties
yeah oh my gosh I don't worry Dave that
that part is zero I like it Breaking
Free from broke check it out at ramsy
solutions.com
store and uh again you get $100 worth of
free bonus items if you get started on
it early we talked about this in our uh
wildly
successful uh live stream last week uh
thank you guys there were 419,000 of you
signed up literally to come aboard not
all of you came but you signed up to
come and uh hundreds of thousands of you
did and it was by far the biggest live
stream Ramsey has ever done uh it was
number one on YouTube that night of
anything wow yeah we blew YouTube up uh
we just about broke the internet with a
number of people signing on our site to
get onto every dollar and saying hey I'm
going to break the cycle which is what
that's for we're breaking a lot of stuff
we're breaking free from broke we're
breaking the cycle I think it's time but
you you talked a little bit about some
of this for your section on that live
stream last week and uh the feedback in
the comments was really excellent I mean
people are hungry to not be stuck
anymore yeah and I wanted to lead with
empathy and go listen there's a lot of
reasons there's a lot of finger you know
pointing we can do a lot of things to
blame this year as to why we're not
going to get ahead and why we have you
even blame the Baby Boomers not really
appreciate that well here's the it
wasn't me blaming it was here's what I'm
seeing out there you know okay people
like you gen Z Millennials are going the
Boomers ruin the housing market Dave
this is why I can't afford a house and
my dad is saying oh shut up you can do
it you paid $113,000 which by the way
I've never lived in a house that I paid
$133,000 for I actually did buy one in
the hood one time
but it was not a it was not a home that
I lived in not not quite chipping Joanna
nope nope not before or after but anyway
the uh yeah the but yeah so we were in
the housing market for sure buying our
our homes for a mere $200,000 or mere
whatever and then um actually the home
before last I paid 353 for it's worth
about a million wow so we know that mean
the appreciation of the housing market
is real and uh Daniel and Rachel were
that Rachel was 10 years old
wow we not bought that so that That's a
classic Boomer story but it's not 13,000
you goobers but it's just one of the
things Dave you know that we I talked
about the fed and Congress and the
president and inflation a lot of things
you can blame it on yeah and exactly
plenty of villains out there the only
person who can fix it is you and the
more we rely and complain the less we're
going to make progress and so that was
one piece of that talk I did and I
unpacked more in the book but the other
piece is we all sort of fell into this
trap I I tell people it's not all of
your fault but it's your responsibility
you weren't taught financi literacy you
were told the path to Upward Mobility is
to take out unlimited student loans and
you got to have a nice car and then you
got to get a house cuz renting is a sin
and a waste of money and we all just
followed down this path and realized
that instead of the American dream we
got delivered the American Nightmare yep
so I led with all with all of that
empathy to go I understand and I'm sorry
but I'm going to show you a way out in
spite of all of that and that was the
heart behind this book here we go
breaking free from broke comes out
tomorrow so order it by midnight tonight
this is January the 15th that we're
recording this so January 16th is launch
day we would love to have you purchase
this go to ramsy solutions.com you're
going to love it go to the store and get
$100 worth of free goodies with the book
for only 20 bucks Breaking Free from
broke by George camel congratulations
George great book Thank you Dave
appreciate you publishing
it
hey guys Ramy Solutions started small
and grew fast because of that rapid
growth there were times when our systems
slowed us down that's why we switched to
net site it works for us and it'll help
your business too whether you're
starting on a card table like I did or
you're on your way to becoming a
multi-million doll Company netw Suite
can scale with you and help you
communicate and plan better because you
know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay net Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netw Suite today and find
out how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
netsuite's free kpi checklist designed
to give you consistently excellent
performance at nets.com Ramsey that's
netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
Ken Coleman ramsy personality number one
bestselling author of the book paycheck
to purpose is my co-host today thank you
for joining us America we're so glad
you're here open phones at
5225 Christopher is with us in Dallas
Texas hi Christopher welcome to the
ramsy
show Dave I am a fellow believer so you
are brother Dave to me it is an honor to
be on your show today man oh we're
honored to have you sir how can we help
all right I'm 28 married with two under
two I work for a church making 43,000 a
year take home we are nearly done with
baby step three and we have enough for
our bills but things are tight I have a
friend a mentor twice my age who is a
successful businessman he knows our
financial situation and offered me a
business opportunity that he has proved
with someone else he suggested trying it
independently or taking a $10,000
investment from him for faster growth
for of course a share in profits I
hesitated because of our close
relationship seeing it as a personal
loan and the thought of trying to work
hard and fast to make back his
investment caused me great anxiety
when I expressed interest in starting
the business without taking his money
because of viewing as a personal loan he
got very upset claiming that it was a
weak excuse for not wanting to admit
that I could make more money on my own
he acted like I was trying to pull one
over on him um and that he was going to
call my bluff but my heart truly did
prioritize the relationship over
potential business gains so my question
is was I wrong to view the investment as
debt and did I miss out on an
opportunity or did I do the right thing
following my gut
and not adding anxiety in my life is
this just a conflict of different ways
to use money no this is a
butthole I mean what kind of guy is a
mentor yeah and then sets you up to take
to get you into something he wants you
into and then is mad because you won't
do it that's not a
mentor he violated Mentor ethics that's
right that's a manipulator oh W that's
what that is that's a manipulative
move yeah big time relationship by the
way isn't anywhere near what you think
it is and let me just say as a guy who I
have still have older mentors in my life
and I talk with them regularly a true
Mentor as Dave said would never react
that way that relationship any isn't
anywhere near what you think it is and I
hate to to tell you that but you need to
be aware of that yeah I would take his
name off The MENTOR plaque yeah he gets
the the mentor plaque beside his name we
have to take that plaque down I like
that we have to put up a different
plaque that just says a guy who wants
money plaque um no that's not I mean a
mentor wants your best interest at heart
and has absolutely zero conflict on
their part and so he was way too
emotionally and otherwise invested in
you doing
this okay like you know if I if I'm
mentoring someone which I don't do very
often for this exact reason but uh and I
I say hey go do this and they don't go
do it they don't get anything from me
but the next time I get ready to tell
them something I might
hesitate but I'm not going to go I told
you not to do that you know um if they
come back and go you told me not to do
that and I screwed this up okay learning
experience that's fine but I'm not you
know I don't have to search someone down
and defend my ego when I'm in the mentor
seat that's that's wild man it's kind of
heartbreaking cuz you you you know you
really depended on this guy really
deflating yeah yeah it was really
deflating and it seemed like really it's
like your dad talking down to
you yeah pretty much
yeah like your dad yelling at you when
you're a grown man I mean it's like
golly that don't work you know you're
confused about that
too I don't know K I mean yeah I I would
say that a mentor needs nothing from you
and should never need anything from you
uh other than if you know uh they call
and it's relational hey pray for me or
something like that but this is this is
a manipulator the reaction really
disgusts me if I'm being honest uh it's
almost like he's a little desperate it
it's it rings of some desperateness of
he's trying to shove 10 grand down your
throat so that he can make a profit
something about it is yeah we're going
to share in the prophets and I'm going
to put you to work over here yeah it
something's off yeah yeah that's wrong
all right Brian's in Salt Lake City hey
Brian how are
you doing great Dave thank you for
taking my call sure what's up so
question I I've followed you for for
years um but uh I I am in a situation
where I'm starting to again um and it is
a little bit of a shame around student
loans so I'm 49 years old and I got
about
$20,000 in student loans and I've been
paying for about 19 years what do you
mean by starting
again I have used your program um and
and had success but I
always counted myself as debt-free
not including my home and not including
my student LS so you used your program
that and said it was mine okay well yes
okay I I get motivated and then I don't
and I I try to just like ignore that
this is out there okay and and obviously
you're calling because that's not
working yeah I'm anxious about it and I
uh I'd love to know kind of what your
thoughts are I I know that there are
some programs out there around like
forgiveness if you've been paying for
what's your household income Brian I
make about $90,000 a year okay the
program is cut your lifestyle and pay
this off in 12 months that's the
program live on
70,000 minus taxes and pay this off in
one year that's about $1,800 a month and
that means you're not going out to eat
and it means you're not going on
vacation and it means you're not doing
half the other crap you've been doing
with your
$90,000 and and you're going to finally
address this head on that's the
program quit looking for a shortcut man
it's not work for you you're going to
have to hit it right straight in the
nose hit the bully in the
nose okay does that make
sense yes it does it's very doable you
got no other debt but this right in the
house I I I own my car oh okay so we
went back to that too okay so how much
what's how how much do you owe on your
car about 15 okay that's not too bad all
right so 35,000 out of
90 so we're debt free in under two years
can we agree you could come up with
175 a year for two years
please please tell me you can do, 1500 a
month or you'll figure out a way to cut
everything but I mean that's what you
got to do it's you you've been trying to
find a way to not do this and it still
go away and and the problem with the
whole thing is there's only really one
solution and it's it's its name is not
Joe Biden I mean there's only one
solution and it's name is Brian uh
because I'm not going to pay it off you
are Brian do you have any margin in your
budget at the end of the
month yeah how
much I I I haven't been good at
budgeting but I'm I'm not I wouldn't
consider myself letting paycheck to
paycheck I have a little bit of savings
give me a round number a given month I
understand you Haven been disciplined
but what's a round number each month
that that you know you've got margin
on I'm not sure if I fully understand
your
question much can you SCP together in
your mind right now a month to throw
with this yeah uh I could I could I
could come up with I think between 700
and $1,000 a month okay to throw all
right and then when you start doing your
budget you're going to get that to 1500
and you're going to be done in under two
years and that doesn't include you going
out and making some extra money a guy
who makes 990,000 has got some skill set
this is about absolute you talked about
motivation I get motivated and then I
lose motivation and you know motivation
is is really about an end result it's
it's a it's a real clear focus on a
result that I want and then the actions
take place naturally that's what real
motivation is what's my motive for
getting up early or eating right or
saving money what's the motive and
that's the end result you've got to
start looking at the end result and no
anxiety over this debt anymore you
mentioned that uh all the other things
if you get clearly focused on that Dave
then the actions take care of themselves
here's the way I look at it sometimes
when I'm looking at this stuff if I'm
going cuz I do that to I do that too I
guess we all do we all do if someone
that I dearly loved one of my
grandchildren life depended on
it could I well yeah absolutely yeah
that's a clear motive I mean you know
and so it's not a it's not a question of
could I it's a question of will I yeah
that's right that's what it comes down
to this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
church mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host Al is in Fort Smith Arkansas hey
Al how are you doing okay Al thank you
so much for taking my call sure and just
just to let you know I am a long long
time listener and this is my first time
ever to call well we're honored how can
we help you today sir I'm honored too so
okay so question is this is about uh
paying off mortgage versus leaving the
money in investment M the mortgage is
about
188,000 at a
3.375 interest we owe about 26 more
years on it and I am 65 years well I'll
be 65 in May the Investments are roughly
600,000 making about anywhere from say 6
to 8% a whole bunch of mutual funds
based on what you told me over the years
so that's my question really is do I go
ahead and pay off the mortgage which
would then bring the Investments down
after paying taxes in the range of say
360 yeah what do you say about 400 yeah
um well the way I do these things is I
reverse engineer it and then I Fe see
how that feels let's pretend that you
had a debt-free house
and $400,000 in
Investments okay would you go borrow
$188,000 at set interest rate to put
more in your
Investments I wouldn't okay I wouldn't
yeah yeah I wouldn't that wakes me up
when I look at it that way and all that
is is the exact same thing but backwards
right right right so
uh the only thing that gives me a little
bit of pause is if you told me you had
600 left over or 800 left over I'd go in
a heartbeat go do it 400's kind of like
it's it's a lot and you've done really
well but you're going to have to be
careful to not you know go go on a
spending spree or something which I
don't think you're going to do it
doesn't sound like you no no and and I
agree with you that 400 would be on that
edge cuz I've ran the retirement
calculators including yours and it puts
me on the edge yeah with no house
payment I mean I always use just on the
high side 8% of the nest EG um and so
you know that's what 20 wases that come
out $32,000 a year right yep or 320,000
yeah 32,000 a year so you know you got
2500 bucks a month coming in plus Social
Security do you have any other money
coming
in uh as a revenue stream no okay we
together we bring in about
118 gross uh per year right now working
you're still working yes I'm still
working yeah okay all right but I mean
if you retired you'd be on 8% of that
Max of your nest egg with no payments in
the world plus Social Security right so
You' have you'd have about half what you
got now coming in but you'd have no
house payment and you'd not be and you
but but of course the longer you work
the more we change that 400 that does
change the equation that's correct yeah
you know plus it'll change Social
Security yeah yeah no not enough to
worry about I wouldn't keep working for
that but I I like working because I like
accomplishing things I like helping
people I I like the sense of uh traction
that it gives me and I don't mind making
money I like doing that too so uh as
long as you're doing that I think I'd
keep going and I'd pay it off today
I mean there's something to be said to
not retire everybody thinks you have to
retire you don't have to retire No in
fact you know retirement can look
however you want it to you want to work
20 hours a week 25 hours a week doing
something that keeps you mentally and
and emotionally talking about wood shop
no you don't have to talking about go do
something in your career field in your
discipline where you make some Bank yeah
and you're doing something you might
business coaching and make more in 20
hours than you're making now right y I
mean something High
with a high level of sophistication I
mean when sometimes people say you know
I'm going to be a fishing guy that's not
what I'm talking about no listen I just
read an article last week that hiring
managers with the wave of gen Z coming
into the workforce they are actively
trying to hire older people the agism
that has been in existence for a while
is dissipating if you're in your 60s you
got some skill and experience you're a
great locker room presence for hiring
managers they'll hire you now so to your
point you can stay active longer and
work and do really well cuz companies
are looking for that older seasoned
veteran if you want to use that football
analogy or basketball and I have not
heard that but I've got an instant
theory that pops into my head what's
your thought well the thing that I'm
hearing all over the place in the
leadership circles that I'm running in
and where I'm doing entary leadership
stuff is that gen Z is highly skilled in
their disciplines but a lot of them have
soft skill problems with relational
skills that's correct and putting that
putting that old dog in there
that's very relational almost to mentor
and train just by their mere presence
seems to make a lot of sense it does and
it also squares with the data that Jin Z
over I want to say about 52% of gen Z
reports saying they want to actually
work in the office because they want to
be mentored keep in mind one of the
effects of this generation of the
helicopter parents Gen X and Millennial
parents is that these kids have been
guided in helicopter to the point that
now when they get in the real world they
actually are craving the good ones with
character not the ones we see on Tik Tok
they're craving some older mentorship in
the office they want that older guy the
tough Old Coach they do someone they
feel safe with hey this old guy is going
to take care of me and show me the road
he loves me but he going to bust me yeah
but they feel Security in that someone's
going to show me what to do so there are
some benefits my point here to our
greater audience is don't assume that
your value drops in your 60s the data
says otherwise h h that's interesting
and certainly that's true for Al we
don't we didn't stay with Al longer to
find out what his actual career is but
right but uh he's obviously making some
money six figures coming into the house
so I was also going to ask you depending
on how how much his house house is worth
does that change your advice there on
that no cuz here's the thing that the
largest line item folks in your budget
at in any time in your life that the
most expensive item in your budget is
housing mhm your biggest expense even if
your house is paid paid for it's still
your biggest expense with taxes
insurance and maintenance right uh so
it's still housing is your biggest
expense when you can do away with the
payment part of that
expense it stabilizes your golden years
it's I mean when you go from 60 to 90
that 30-year period of time with no
house payment with that kind of
stability it changes your emotional
state and therefore it it actually
affects your health mhm because you're
not as Dr John says you're not carrying
around that stress between your shoulder
blades uh which debt is stress between
your shoulder blades whether you
actually remember it's there or not you
don't right and I like that and this is
safe money too because as they get older
maybe they need to go into some assisted
care that house is sitting there that's
money waiting for them to cash out yeah
and it's it's it it just it
it is one of the two things that we see
with the people that have the first $1
to5 million of of net worth your first
million up to your first 5 million is a
paid for house and a big old 401K and
he's got both yep now or he's about to
have both if he does that so Al's done a
really good job yeah he's in the top
probably four or 5% of Americans
financially in his situation he's done
an excellent work um and even at that
we're saying H I wish it was a little
bit more sure you know but he's making
100 a year so you thought you start
throwing load that 401k up load the IRAs
up anything else you can load up for the
next and work three more years four more
years yeah that that all of a sudden
then that becomes a no-brainer right
that changes everything if you had to
retire today on that that's when it kind
of gives you I want to take a little bit
of a breath there right pretty crazy but
um isn't that a wonderful thing though
that that guy has been listening all
those years wow to us and has gone and
done the stuff and is in really really
good shape congratulations sir very
proud of you very very very well done
and um you know you folks you just don't
want to get to retirement and the only
thing you have is the government which
is well known for its ability to handle
money is going to take care of me that's
a pretty dumb idea that's the definition
of insanity this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at CH ministries.org
budget
[Music]
n Ken Coleman Ramsey personality number
one bestselling author of the book
paycheck to purpose is my co-host today
thank you for joining us America Josh
and Claire are with us in De Moine Iowa
hi guys how are
you we are good cool how come we
help um well we had a question if we
should sell our house and move and rent
or if we should stay put and the reason
we're asking is because we have some
debt and we both Drive about 40 minutes
um each way to our jobs which wasn't how
it was when we bought the house
originally okay all right uh how much
that do you
have um combined without the house is
about 100,000 on
what um
86 ,000 on student loans about 10,000 on
a
car um yeah and that's that's it what's
your household income
uh about 990,000 a year okay cool all
right and uh what's the house
worth um about
200 what do you want
it say that again what do you owe on
it uh about
175,000 okay so by the time you sell it
you don't have much Equity of
any no okay so it doesn't pay off any
debt it just gets rid of the house and
you move
closer
M okay so it's not doesn't it doesn't
pay off of $100,000 in debt right am I
missing something so we're just
wondering it you just want to move
closer to
work well that and the cost of renting
versus paying the mortgage is it worth
to be closer to work well that's what I
want to know so what's the difference
give us the difference between what the
rent would be if you move closer versus
your current
mortgage our current mortgage is about
1,500 um in rent will be about 15 to
1700 okay all right so let's pretend
it's, 1500 all you did was just trade a
mortgage payment for
a for a house payment but you got U
considerable blocks of time back which I
would then use to make extra money and
work more MH and get this debt paid off
that would be the goal I think just
doing that and spinning your wheels I
would not
do okay we also um just had a baby boy
about three months ago
congratulations thanks so we're still
trying to figure that out too yeah well
you're not sleeping now so that's
it that's true I want to know what
Claire thinks Claire would if all things
were equal would you rather be closer to
where you work or is it easier to change
jobs as opposed to change the house
situation I I know you guys have thought
through
this yeah so the um original thought was
that when we bought the house I was like
15 minutes from my job and Josh was like
40 minutes from his which we knew was a
sacrifice being in the Metro we knew
somebody would have to drive um but
right now um Josh just finished his
master's um in educational leadership
and so we're not even really sure how
long we're going to stay in De Mo but it
feels like he leaves at 6:30 and doesn't
get home till 5:30 I'm an occupational
therapist so I'm my schedule is just
flexible everywhere and so it feels like
yeah the time it's hard to figure out
like is it worth the same cost and the
effort to sell a house to versus rent
but like we would get some time back and
especially with a newborn it feels like
time is more important than everything
right now so yeah I don't know we're
just trying to balance that out what's
Your Gut telling you before we weighed
in Where Were You
leaning I was leaning towards selling to
get time back but I that's the call
would so as a parent I'm thinking
through that and I'm also thinking about
the fact that with hubs here Josh
getting the Masters we don't know we're
going to be in De Moine long term I like
the flexibility and it looks like the
rent is a wash basically you said it's
about $200 maybe difference and to get
that time back Dave said as Dave said we
got that time to hustle a little bit pay
some debt but I think renting at this
point gives us options if we're moving I
I kind of like that as a as a a
bridge was it what do you think Dave is
that I feel like options right now are
better since they don't know they're
there long
term yes um I what my fear is and you
just if I were I always try to figure
out if it's me and Sharon doing
something I'm like how can we screw this
up right and we go okay if we don't if
we do this part of that then it's bad
and if we do the whole thing then it's
good right kind of thing and so we have
to we all sometimes we even write that
down at our house you know we like type
it out and go this is the whole plan
okay okay simply moving and getting time
back and becoming a renter no not a good
trade if that's all you do but if
there's a move out of town and up on his
career in the future good play if
there's a a you take some of the time
you've redeemed for the newborn and some
of the time to make some money and clear
up this $100,000 in debt good play uh
and because you've got the flexibility I
mean if Josh is going to be home more
maybe CLA picks up more hours on some
nights and maybe Josh picks up some
stuff Saturday mornings um and he
continues to look for a different
permanent solution with his Masters it's
a much higher paying thing as well so
all of that to say three years from
today as a result of this and some extra
hustle and maybe a move I want you guys
Dead free and owning a
house yeah it can't be you get over
there and you go well we've got a lot of
time with the little boy now and we are
renters for the next 10 years because we
spin our Wheels no no no no no no no no
no that would be a bad plan I agree and
that's that's how I could screw it up if
I were in your shoes because so you got
to be careful cuz what's driving this is
the
newborn and um if the newborn gets all
of this uh not going to be good for the
newborn's long term not going to be good
for anybody's long term if he gets all
of the the the juice from this move uh
so yeah that that's um a similar thing
but dissimilar but similar Sharon and I
sold our home and but we had made about
three different changes at the same time
we had our children in a private school
we were they were 45 minutes away so an
hour and a half each way 45 over 45 back
twice a day yeah to go get them and pick
them up so we got rid of that we got rid
of the private school because we moved
into a count this County which is the
number one County for education in the
state and we moved into that County and
uh and we rented and we sold the house
and we cleaned up a little bit of last
little bit of debt that surviv the
bankruptcy some IRS stuff so we cleaned
up debt we got rid of the commute we uh
got rid of the private school and all
three of those things so that we could
rent for two years so that we could move
up and that was a move we made almost 30
years ago so that was a good move but if
we had
just consumed the difference in time and
consumed the difference in money and
stayed a renter that would not have been
a good move you see what that that's but
we talked about those exact things at
that exact time very clearly it's real I
mean stuck in my head and you could ask
Sharon rsey to this day she hated that
freaking rental house she hated that
kitchen she can describe that kitchen
with anger in her eyes to this day she
wanted out of there which is great that
was all IA we were not supposed to be
there for a while but for a little bit
it was camping so chill out it's camping
it's a camp stove leave the stove alone
right so it's a rental house for God's
sakes you know that kind of stuff so
that but that's the kind of stuff you
want to fight against Josh and CLA you
guys are awesome you're awesome parents
you're obviously thinkers you're and
you're working together to make these
decisions all of these things say you're
going to make the right decision yeah I
think you sell it and move I do too and
I I Echo everything Dave said Josh and
Clair here's what I'd like you all to do
I think you have to have a dream
conversation tonight about what Josh's
next move or moves could be and let's
figure that out that will determine the
rest of this that's what Dave just laid
out so beautifully like where are we
headed what's the 20e 25 year play and
what's the next move and if a move out
of De Moine for Josh is the next right
move then everything else Falls in place
so make that decision first the baby's
fine baby has no concept of time you're
tired I get it your heart hurts you want
to be with him you can hang on a little
bit longer there's nothing cuter than a
brand new B no and so you got to make
that big decision first John Maxwell our
friend once said make the big decisions
early and manage them for years this is
one of those
decisions that's a big big rocks in the
glass first then the next little then
they put the sand in last it'll hold a
lot more that's right put the big rocks
in yeah that old that old analogy or
metaphor that people use it's a good
good uh object lesson for the youth
group right yeah it is it is this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
n
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality number
one bestselling author of the book from
paycheck to purpose and host of the Ken
Coleman podcast is my co-host today be
sure you jump in and talk to us the
phone number is
5225 Abraham is in Lincoln Nebraska hi
Abraham how are
you hello I'm doing good thank you for
taking uh my call today and helping out
sure what's
up so essentially I I'm in the uh
chemical engineering field and in my
current position I have a great manager
and I have a great job and a job that I
enjoy a lot and I get to travel quite a
bit for however I do know that uh in
comparison to other uh positions out
there that are of similar work or that
would have the same experience that I
have I can probably get 20 to $40,000
more what do you me with that in mind
I'm sorry what do you
make 100,000 okay right so you think
that you could change companies and make
140 doing exactly what you do
now uh probably even less uh less stress
and less work to be
honest
okay so my question
is what is if if I would like to keep my
current uh employment but with the added
benefit of the additional salary what is
the best way to bring that up with my
manager um and how do I assess even if
it's worth it at all and just go pursue
a different uh how big how big a
company uh it is a it is a global
company okay so it's not 100% up to your
manager uh no but it is run pretty their
companies run pretty lean and uh it's a
very it's similar to your company where
it's a single owned uh s owned by a
single person and that that family
culture kind of penetrates through and
through okay so here's what I want to
dive into two times you've
mentioned uh the idea that this is
either highly stressful maybe you've got
some balance issues is that true am I
hearing that what's going on with that
the stress part that you've
mentioned it's uh uh there's a lot of
requirements and a lot of expectations
that I am able to meet um but it's uh
it's still enjoyable yeah so let me ask
you this if I called your boss right now
and Dave and I made it happen behind the
scenes and we called you back and said
hey good news we got you that 20 to
let's let's split the difference we got
you to 30k bump what would your reaction
be I'd be very happy would you even be
thinking about going to these other
companies where you could make more and
and do less would you even be thinking
about it okay so I think that has to be
the perspective so my advice is pretty
boilerplate on this I'm I'm sure Dave
will weigh in but but I'm going to put
myself uh in your shoes and I'm but I'm
thinking about your leader and Dave's
right in a company this large it's the
sole decision on your raise is not in
your Leader's hands that's going to have
to go up and so you've got to make a
case with your leader that your leader
can then decide how they could make the
case so I would not go in just with the
data that says all right I've looked at
other positions out in the marketplace
and when I compare these by the way you
got to know that they're Apples to
Apples they rarely are but if they're
not Apples to Apples you got to call
that out too and you say okay here's the
comparison based on skill and experience
and this is the range that I see out in
the marketplace however I want to be
here and you tell them why you want to
be there tell them how much you
appreciate them what you've told Dave
and I then you say hey I'd like to have
a conversation with you about a growth
plan to where I can add more value and
you and I are on the same page about
what that value is how we measure it and
and if we accomplish that a path to
where I can make this kind of money a
and be more competitive in the
marketplace based on this I want your
take on this is there a growth plan that
we can work on and and now I'm bringing
the leader into the conversation and
that leader sees that you're grateful
that you're hungry but that you've got
some humility and you're not asking for
a raise you're going hey I'd like to
grow to this what could a path look like
that on and I know that I've got to have
more responsibility I've got to deliver
results that we agree on we measure
those and with that comes more uh
responsibility and more income that's
how I would approach that because now
you're going to find out two things
number one what your relationship is
with your leader and how they're
handling this and how they're
communicating it and two you give them
something that they get to build as well
and they've got some ownership because
they've got to take this up as Dave has
pointed out so this is a partnership not
you demanding something and I don't
sense that in your spirit but the way
you approach this they've got to have in
because they've got to present this plan
up they're running a p&l
yes uh I'm not sure what a pnl is profit
and loss they've got they're running a
business unit they're running a business
unit and responsible for profitability
and you when you get a raise guess what
that is that's more expenses for them
yeah now now to to to be frank my my U
my relationship with my manager is
excellent and we've actually we've
actually had a similar type of
conversation that you're that you are
describing a few years ago and he's and
he's he and the company has G have given
me many opportunities so now for example
I do
projects uh in a lot of different
countries right however I want them to
give you opportunities I also want them
give you
money that's the that's
you so have you gotten uh more
opportunities but no money over the last
couple years give us the track record
here yeah I mean uh so I've been
employed for 5 and a half years with the
company progressed quite a bit level of
responsibilities and the projects that
I'm doing for my what about your
financial
progression it's been I think uh close
to 25,000 increase over five years and
years five and a half years with with
with with Pro here's what here's what I
want you to do I I want you to do better
research to go with Ken's suggest
question than you have done to date I
want some detailed written compensation
studies from LinkedIn monster.com
whatever showing this is the detailed
description of these people and this is
what the average person makes not I ran
into a guy who's in our industry who's
making X okay I want I want to I want I
want you to really make the case like
you were going before a judge and you
were a lawyer okay and this is the
evidence of what the if I'm going to
sell a car here's the evidence it's not
I had a feeling or I had a friend once
who sold a car like that I go and I pull
up kbb.com I'll pull up Traders and I
pull up two or three things I find
several examples of this car I show them
to the person I'm trying to do the deal
with and go this is what the reality of
this car is and then they do that so cuz
let me tell you what's happened around
here at Ramsey is we'll be on the other
side of your conversation we've had
people come in and tell us that they're
worth $440,000 more and then we show
them that they're not when we do the
comp when we do when we do the detailed
study and then sometimes they come in
and tell us that and we do the comp
study and we go oh crap they're right
they're underpaid and we pay them we
raise their income and both of those
have happened this year but uh sometimes
the person bringing it doesn't do their
homework and I want you to do your
homework before you have this next
conversation and say I don't want to
leave but I do want to make Market how
are we going to work this out this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial peace and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for joining us America we
appreciate all the help you've given us
in the past year just recently we hit
number one on Apple podcast among all
podcasts in the world that's kind of
mind-blowing over a billion downloads of
this show now that's really mind-blowing
billion with a B that's like a lot thank
you guys we appreciate that and you know
what's part part of the reason is as you
guys are helping us you're sharing the
show thank you for sharing it clicking
the Subscribe button the follow button
the share button the like button the
five star reviews all of these things
matter a lot in the old algorithms on
podcasts and YouTube and talk radio you
just tell people spread the word when
you see a good movie read a good book or
hear a good show and you've been doing
that for us thank you thank you thank
you we really really appreciate it our
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for home services
that first time you turn on your heating
system every year it can smell funny and
maybe even make some noises if the noise
hasn't stopped since then don't put it
off anymore contact air serve to service
your HVAC air serve is a neighborly
brand dedicated to Superior Service so
find them at neighbor.com Ramsey today
today's question comes from Joseph in
Georgia I'm 22 and didn't go to college
I feel stuck in this customer service
job I have making a little less than
30,000 a year after taxes I had a few
other jobs besides the one I just
mentioned and my favorite was an asphalt
paving I was making the same hourly rate
but within a few months I made close to
the that yearly amount due to all of the
overtime the paving job left me with no
more than around 7 to n hours to eat
dinner shower and sleep almost every day
which I hated and it drained me should I
go back to that job or go study
something that could let me be in a
similar position I'm in now but
potentially make more than what I
currently do uh okay uh you're 22 number
one uh number
two I'm seeing a lot of these videos on
social media that after my job
I only have S to n hours to eat shower
and sleep almost every day um those are
some kind of life that's kind of how it
is uh when I come home from my very uh
non labor intensive job here at Ramy
Solutions I'm in bed by 10:00 there's
lash marks on your back I think I know
but I only have as I see it about four
to five hours and uh my life's pretty
great so I think we need a perspective
shift here so I'll leave it alone so I
don't sound like the old man here um but
you need a new perspective on what your
long-term goals are as well as your
short-term financial goals what I would
say cuz I worked in the masonry industry
in college hardest job I ever worked in
my life I was on the job site at 700
a.m. Dave mixing the mortar dumping the
mortar in a wheelbarrow Wheeling the
wheelbarrow around the job site which
you've ever been on a home job site
that's like a mogul ski course that's
how you develop those muscles that's why
I am the bronny man I am today Dave it's
stuck with me and uh and then when I was
done Distributing the mortar I got to
tell the rest of the story it was brick
tongs and you repeat this process all
day long it was a 10-hour day it was the
most backbreaking work of my life I get
it the asphalt paving is a very very
intense job in this situation I would
look at most of the trades I really
would uh because the amount of Education
you need is minimal the cost is minimal
but the long-term return on the
investment of time and money in the
trades is absolutely
spectacular uh in fact for those of you
that are younger and you think I'm kind
of the old Boomer I'm actually an exer
but just go on Tik Tok it's where you
like to hang out and look at all the Tik
toks of of plumbers and HVAC people that
are making well into the six figures uh
the trades are the great secret right
now for this Young Generation so I would
be looking that direction but if you
want to win young Joseph you're going to
be looking at that same schedule you
shouldn't be having 10 in 12 hours of
free time if you're serious about
working it's just not a reality and I
don't know where that came from this
idea that I need eight to 10 hours a day
of free time I don't get it unless it's
the College
schedule
uh a lot of partying going on
um uh yeah I don't think asphalt's in
your future see I I think you've boiled
this down to two bad things and trying
to choose between them mhm a bad $30,000
your customer service job and a
backbreaking asphalt job um those aren't
the only two choices obviously the
choices are infinite and so uh pick up
Ken's book from paycheck to purpose
start thinking about where you want to
be when you're 30 if you're
22 clearly Define that and then start
asking yourself why you want to do that
if you just want to do it for money you
pick the wrong thing you want to pick if
you just want to do it for passion but
you're going to be broke you picked the
wrong thing so you want to make some
good money doing something you love and
that gives you energy and then the time
will fly by and you won't feel put upon
for having worked an entire day so
um yeah so I I think you got to say you
know what have I got to do and don't
pick something based on
lifestyle don't pick something based on
money pick something that gives you
energy and that is gives you meaning and
that you can make money and again the
time will fly by I mean the old saying
if you um if you pick work you love um
every day is a vacation uh well that's
that's a bit of an exaggeration every
day is not a vacation for me and I love
what I do yeah um but some days are
harder than others and some days are you
know even the thing you do turns out to
be work but but most days you know I do
this show for three hours every day and
I have for 30 years and those three
hours fly by I look up and go wow I just
just a minute I was on there it's The
Company You Keep I mean how could you
not enjoy 3 hours of meeting that's it
that's it and hey can we the bronny man
over here the Brony brick Tong guy I
know it's terrible hey you know what
Benjamin Franklin actually said this you
know you see all these quotes about
these old famous people from history he
actually said this and it's this advice
that that Joseph and this Young
Generation needs to understand he said
early to bed early to rise makes a a man
healthy wealthy and wise and I think we
hear that when we're little kids at some
point we think oh it's a cute little
nursery rhyme no that's actually a man
if you read and study Franklin I know
you and I have the man was maniacal
about his daily schedule very
intentional and as a result one of the
greatest uh citizens of the world forget
American history I'll guarantee you that
has played an element in the level of
success I've personally enjoyed I know
it has I am a um when I was growing up I
was naturally a night person MH I mean
in college I could stay up till 2:00 in
the morning I never thought anything
about it and I sleep till 10 y you know
and I never took any early classes cuz I
was lazy didn't get out of bed I was the
same way and uh but when I uh graduated
from college got married became an adult
and uh you know quit partying all the
time met God you know I started going
okay I'm going to I'm going to dedicate
the first hours of the morning to my
mind my body and my relationship with
God and so uh I'm going to read I'm
going to do some kind of exercise I'm
going to spend some time with Sharon I'm
going to spend some time in prayer and
with scripture and Sharon and I have
gotten up at 5:00 a.m. for I don't know
uh 30 years wow yeah and we go and you
know we were old people before we were
old people and you know we go to bed and
uh we get up and you know by the time I
get to the office at 8:30 I mean I've
done half a day's work and one way or
another around the house and you know uh
all that stuff and I'm not bragging on
me I'm just saying the stuff that I get
out of my scripture in my prayer time in
the morning the stuff I get out of
reading a good non-fiction book in the
morning making sure I'm connected with
Sharon and we've got the day laid out
and by the time I get to work I'm not
stumbling into the first meeting fuzzy
and hung over that's right you know it's
exactly right and I haven't you know in
in 30 plus years so that's you just you
that that you know worried about my
leisure time yeah instead I've got a a
early to bed early to rise makes you
healthy wealthy and wise and it does do
that it does do that Franklin was on to
something there so something to think
about you know you set your morning
schedule I met a guy when I first met
God that was knew the Bible inside and
out and I said how do you how do you do
this he goes well I I read this many I
read 3 hours a morning on scripture I'm
like how you read 3 hours he goes well I
start at 4:00 yeah that'll do it how do
you start at 4 how do you get up he goes
well if you want to get up that early
you got to go to bed early yep oh
there's that okay this is the Ramsey
[Music]
sh
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
[Applause]
apply
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personalities my
co-host Cammy is with us in Sacramento
hi Cammy welcome to the Ramsey
Show well you got to push the button old
Dave did I push it I did push it hi
Cammy how are you I'm good thanks for
taking my call sure what's
up I am calling because I want your
Insight on how I should start with
long-term investing as a 21-year-old
with no debt no credit and about $40,000
in savings why to go yeah what a great
head start thank you you're obviously
very smart how did you learn all
this um well Dave I have fantastic
parents who are huge fans of yours I
think I've been listen to you since my
drive back's from kindergarten
so you're a financial peace baby okay I
love it that's awesome well then you
know that we teach folks to stay out of
debt which you have done to have a plan
which you have done uh to have an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses which you have done and then
start investing
15% of your income into your retirement
first with a match second with a Roth
and third just make sure you get 15% in
there uh and once you're doing that any
money you have above that to save and
invest I'd start saving towards my first
house okay and I'm curious about having
the no credit what your thoughts are on
that because I know you talk about
buying your house in cash and and and
kind of your process with that well
buying a house with cash means you don't
need credit number one number two if you
don't have credit and you want to buy a
home with a mortgage you do that with
what's called manual
underwriting not all mortgage companies
know how to do that anymore Church Hill
mortgage that we've endorsed for almost
30 years does know how to do that and
they can help you do that if you're
steady on your rent and you've been on
your job two years you have a good solid
down payment you do not need a credit
score to buy a house you get the same
premium excellent interest rate as if
you had a very high credit score when
you do a manually underwritten situation
you're not there today because you set
some of your 40 aside for your emergency
fund some of it aside towards your first
house but that's going to not put you in
the housing market today but you're well
on your way and you'll certainly be
there in your early 20s without a doubt
so excellent question Cammy way to go
wow yeah I wish more people would pay
attention to these calls uh fast forward
she starts investing 15% right now she
hits millionaire status at what age
roughly 34 yeah that's she have net
worth of a million dollars probably in
about 14 years by the way the American
dream is alive and well yeah okay and
that's a gen Z that's
right by the way yeah for those of you
that are JZ and think that oh it's all
over it can't happen oh no you know oh
God all the whining that's out there
it's just great drama it's like every
generation that has come along thinks
that the generation before them stole
all the opportunity that's right there's
nothing left the old people took it all
oh brother and the old people every
generation that's come along think the
next generation's a bunch of doofuses
it's true it's generational neither one
or the truth I mean this generation's
full of wonderful people like Cammy
we've got a building full of Camis
that's right I mean half of our 1,100
people that work here are under 30 so
officially gen Z wow I mean I we four
new people start this morning I went up
onboarding hung out with them and talked
to them really sharp oh God they're so
smart and they're going to be great team
members and they care deeply and uh you
know I just explaining to them this is
going to be the hardest place you've
ever worked because you're working with
smart people that really care deeply
yeah and they're not into internal
politics they're just into getting the
work done and uh it makes it really
difficult cuz you got to I mean when
you're playing for the Super Bowl with
the best in the world you got to play
hard you know it's good it's a good
thing but there's there's cammies all
over the place man they're all over the
I'm I'm thrilled with this GNC
generation I think they're Amazing Joe's
in Scranton Pennsylvania hi Joe how are
you how you doing Dave thanks for having
me sure what's up nothing I just have a
question for you okay so I've been been
I've been investing in real estate for
like the past 15 years um I got kind of
lucky I didn't use your advice I used
leverage but I sold it everything I am
debt free except my mortgage the issue
now is the price of real estate the the
rate of return on it it's like really
bad so I'm thinking should I keep what I
have go work on something else just wait
be patient I'm just me my way for a
little confused what we should do like
she works full-time but it's kind of
what I should do with my life now um
just looking for some
advice how much money you got
stacked um about 90 grand um cash and I
owe the only day I have is my mortgage
and I owe about 68 Grand and you're not
working um well I work I manage my
rentals I currently have about 10 units
Oh I thought you
sold I sold a few of them and I kept and
they're all the ones you have are all
debt free correct oh good okay all right
uh real estate I've been buying real
estate since
1982 mhm and uh real estate always goes
through ups and downs in terms of rates
of return and pricing all over the place
and so um you know it's very difficult
uh following Fouch pandemic to buy a
good deal because house prices as you
know shot through the roof and they
stayed there they didn't come back down
and so the um that makes the rate of
return weird and so it sometimes it
takes rent prices a while to catch up
rents spiked as housing price spiked but
not as much
translation the rate of return went down
and so uh you know on houses in
particular residential is a little more
fickle a little weirder um so I I
have I buy a lot of real estate I love
real estate but I have ebbed and flowed
throughout the decades as to you know
there's times I just sit on the sideline
and watch the craziness I'm not getting
in I don't I don't want I don't like the
rules and today's one of them today the
r return I agree with you are not really
high but if I can find something at a
deal for whatever the reason if it's
because the marketplace is slow down or
because I just stumble upon something
that's a deal uh then I I I will step
into it and we'll go do it and sometimes
the deal is made up of the situation and
it has nothing to do with the economy
locally or nationally it's just you find
a you find a distressed property of some
sort or a distressed seller of some sort
and you're able to slip in with some
cash and do a great deal so I'm not
completely sidelined but I'm also not
just running around buying everything in
sight now I'll tell you when I did buy
everything in sight I dropped almost
every coin of cash I had into real
estate in uh in 2008 and N because I was
buying stuff at 15 and2 cents on the
dollar after the the 2008 crash it was
the best buying time in my adult life um
and I've never bought as much since I
mean we bought everything we could get
our hands on and some of the best
properties I own today
uh rate of return wise are obviously
those because I got nothing in them um
and so but it does e in flow so just put
yourself on the sideline until you get a
great deal or until the marketplace
shifts and more deals are out there
either one's fine uh in meantime you may
want to do something for an income
because managing 10 units is not a
full-time job well the other thing I
want to know is he's got 90,000 set
aside and he still has a house payment
it's his only debt I'm probably going to
clear that I'd want to clear that yeah
especially while we're sitting on the
Sidelines yep so the 90 goes into the
house yeah if you don't stumble upon a
deal to put that back into pretty quick
um I'm probably going to go ahead and
clear that mortgage and then start
stacking cash out of the rentals and out
of whatever else I can do I mean you may
want to go into the service side of the
real estate business go ahead and get
your license become a property manager
manage other people's properties and
yours um I did that at one point many
many moons ago um I can tell you it
wasn't my favorite thing to do but um
but I did do it for some extra cash flow
at the time it worked out good it was
fine it just G it's uh it's a but anyway
if you want to do that instead of go get
a job you can do that right that's a
different way of approaching this good
question man sounds like you got a good
run going this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
la
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken colan Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones here at
88255 225 Ken I just got a report in
that your
assessment the uh getting clear yeah the
get clear assessment get clear
assessment uhhuh uhhuh is uh one of our
most profitable product lines we knew we
had a good year it's been really fun and
rewarding to see that people getting
aware of who they really are the way we
translated that around Ramsey is it
means we have something that's helping a
lot of people yeah because otherwise we
don't make money on it if we make money
it means that we helped a lot of people
there's a correlation between those two
things if we sell a lot of books that's
a lot of somebody got helped right same
kind of thing we have three new products
that came out uh late fall just in time
for Christmas all three are doing very
very well and and also Rachel Cruz my
daughter's new book in the children's
space a children's book I'm glad for
what I have her first ever Illustrated
Kids book hit number one in the kids
lists and it is a great beautiful little
book and a lot of fun for the kiddos
Breaking Free from broke unbelievable
data and lots of snark George camel uh
book comes out on J January the 16th if
you hear this before then you can get
all $100 worth of goodies if you order
the book early uh included in the $20
price and Jade ww's uh quick read money
is not a math problem hit number five on
the bestseller list this weekend Oh
fantastic Jade Jade is officially a
national bestseller her first time to be
on one of the lists so we're
congratulating her and running around
this place screaming and yelling and
celebrating on her behalf so all of
those things are available at ramsy
solutions.com be sure and check them out
Allison's with us in Jacksonville
Florida hi Allison welcome to the Ramsey
show thank you Dave how are you today
better than I deserve what's up in your
world well my husband and I are in a
little bit of financial distress and uh
we're looking to see where we can cut
corners and we would like to reduce our
car payments um one of our car payments
is $58 and the other one is like
$644 and uh but we're upside down on
them and so we don't have the money to
pay the difference of the upside down
part and we don't wondered what is your
advice on what we would do in that
situation boy you're deep in it yeah
we're deep in it what's the uh what's
your household
income uh 115,000 and I'm looking for
and I'm looking for a job oh you're not
working he makes 115 right okay good
what will you make when you get what
will you be making when you get your job
maybe about 1,200 a month why so
low um because it's just a cashier type
job do you have any previous work
experience uh as a photographer I have
was a photographer for had my own
business but I wasn't a very good
business person I didn't make how old
are you too I'm 58 and he's 66 okay you
make you can make $20 an hour which is a
lot more than $1,400 a month at freaking
Target okay so I mean you you're going
to do a lot better than you think you're
going to do if you get out there and
poke around a little bit even on
entry-level cashier you can do a lot
better than what you're thinking anyway
um the car that has the $600 $650 car
payment what do you owe on that
car um I think we owe around
24,000 really what's it
worth um I don't
know how do you know you're up Shide
down um my husb my husband tells me
these things okay um it's an it's an
electronic Mini Cooper uh or electric
Mini Cooper so did you guys get did you
get screwed on the entrance interest
rate CU that's a very high payment for
24,000 yeah yeah our our our um credit
rating is real bad so they stuck it to
you with a they electrified you with the
electric Mini Cooper yeah that's what
they did yeah okay so uh what year is
that uh it's a
2020 uh three it's 23 okay sorry so you
just recently made this mistake yeah yes
okay all right so here let's just give
you some number as an example to answer
your question do you know who you owe
the money
to yes
who we owe it to the um uh Mini Cooper
Financial okay what about the other car
who's it owed to uh byar Credit Union ah
okay and uh that's the 550 do you know
what you owe on that
one uh 20,000 okay I'm going to use that
one as an example okay
let's pretend that when you look it up
you find out that that car is worth
$155,000 and you owe 20 on it and you're
upside down $5,000 you follow my example
yes I have no idea I'm just making this
up to show you how it works okay okay
you have two
options three options one is you live on
beans and rice rice and beans and save
up
$5,000 sell the car for1 15 add five to
it go down the credit union get the
title and give it to the buyer okay
option number two is borrow the 5,000
somewhere
else option number three on that one is
you talk to the credit union about
letting you sign a note for the
difference okay now you're going to owe
5,000 instead of 20,000 and on the other
one you're 7,000 upside down maybe I
don't know making that up and you're
going to owe 7,000 instead of
24,000 and so now we got a total of
$122,000 in debt instead of a total of
$44,000 in debt so we're moving in the
right direction we get a couple of
beater cars get this mess cleaned up and
pay cash for a little bit of a move up
in car out of the beaters a little bit
later the the credit union let me sign a
note for the difference they might go
down sit and talk to the manager with
you and your husband because here's the
situation if they repo the car they're
not going to get even 15 for it so they
have currently an unsecured note for
five and a secured note for 15 all we're
asking them to do is admit
it okay you understand what I'm saying
and sign sign a note note for the
difference for the difference let let me
sell it for what it'll bring I'll bring
the buyer in and I'll sign a note for
the difference because these these
payments are killing me and they might
even loan you the money for the amount
that you're upside down in that other
one all right i' I'd mess with them if
you especially if you got a long
relationship with that credit union but
go sit down in person and talk to the
credit union manager don't do this by
email or over the phone easy to tell
somebody no unless they're sitting
across a desk from you okay do you have
any idea how many miles you have on that
Mini Cooper the
electric uh around 50 you also need one
of the assignments I'm going to add to
this I'm just doing some quick web
research so I don't want to hold you to
this but I would be looking to see if
that thing is worth uh what you what you
owe on it right now or pretty close to
it you might be able to uh get you might
be able to break even on that one which
would be the play but you got to you got
to check that out right now what's it
worth right now if you sell it private
seller now dealership's not going to
give you what it's worth but private
seller I would be looking at that blue
book value today the thing on the market
on Craigslist and trader.com and get it
sold for 25,000 yeah instead of instead
of losing money you gain money cuz I'm
looking over Ken's shoulder right now I
see 27,000 29,000 might be the value on
this thing yes yeah okay so y'all look
at that and let's make sure cuz if your
husband is looking at tradein Value only
instead of private sale then that's how
he determined you're upside down then
he's just signing you up again for
another mess cuz y'all really suck at
doing car
deals I mean everything you've touched
around cars really sucks so I'm I'm
really not trusting your husband's input
at this point I'm not mad at him but I'm
just saying y'all need to do detail
research sell these things for as much
as you can sell them for to an
individual borrow the difference or sign
a note the difference and quit signing
up for ridiculous interest rates and
stupid but car deals that oh my God an
electric Mini Cooper
yeah yeah wow somebody got impulse fever
yeah and it wasn't an electric impulse
I'm just saying I was wondering if
that's where you were going oh man and
by the way I just pulled up just for our
friend and Allison and all of you that
kind of Wonder was Dave what is he
talking is it going to work yes I'm
looking at some really decent cars in
the Jacksonville area under $5,000 folks
it is doable what Dave played off 2003
Honda Accord EX 4 4900 a Honda will run
for three 300 decades until God comes
back I'm telling you a lot longer than
electric Mini Cooper wheel it's true
actually gag this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
n
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality hosted the Ken Coleman
podcast and number one bestselling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
is my co-host today thank you for
joining us we're so glad you're here the
phone number is
5225 Holden is with us he's in Austin
Texas hi Holden how are
you hi I'm good thanks Dave and Ken
thanks for having me on sure what's up
um I am 39 I live with my wife and two
daughters uh we are debt free thanks to
my wife and to your plan uh we do owe
260,000 on a house worth about
550 I'm an industrial designer with a
master's degree I was making 80 about a
year ago before I was laid off um and I
made about 50
Contracting uh this past
year uh and I'm considering a career
change uh between my undergraduate and
grad school I was a substitute teacher
for a few years had some long-term jobs
and I I love teaching
uh I've had some good my design career
I've had some good moments but I've
lacked some fulfillment and I've always
felt called to go back to
teaching and I'm calling for advice on
how to make that decision and how to
look at it from a financial perspective
is that K through
12 yes I like to teach art okay and have
you considered the higher education
level I have uh was looking at a
community college here um and haven't
been able to get my foot in the door and
what is the pay range do you know the
difference between uh community college
professor versus K through 12 in Austin
the Austin area yeah starting it would
be about 10,000 more at the community
college well what are those totals so
what's the number about 53 53,000
for uh K through 12 and maybe 12 around
65 at the community college
okay uh and you've substitute taught
enough to know that you really like that
environment and the reason I'm asking
this is because uh I absolutely respect
the calling and if you've tasted enough
of it to where you know The Good the Bad
and the Ugly I think it's a it's it's a
different deeper conversation but
candidly the public school environment
Across the Nation as a whole is not very
good the National Education
association's own numers show that 52% %
of the current teaching population are
considering leaving because it is a very
difficult environment and so I'm leading
with that uh because I want to make sure
you know what you're heading
into right do you I did teach for yeah I
I taught in some difficult schools in uh
in Baltimore City uh I I had long-term
jobs during that stretch teaching for
half a school year two times so
um and uh yeah I understand that it uh
that it is difficult but I I feel ready
okay if you had both options on the
table and let's go A Step Above
Community College let's go higher ed uh
Community College level and then K
through2 if you had a job waiting at all
three of those levels which one would
you
choose I would choose the K through 12
because of that that age group you
really have a real draw to that age
group because of that yeah and to teach
art yeah no I get that I'm sorry they
don't teach art in a four-year
University well my degree is in
industrial design so I
know that wasn't what Ken asked you yeah
you qualified this and you qualified to
force you into this answer that you've
predetermined is the way to go that
makes you
happy because you've got
I don't know why you can't teach art in
a four year just because you have an
industrial arts degree right
right I would definitely be open to that
possibility teaching in higher well you
have to look at that because here's what
I'm getting at when I ask this question
is it about
instructing the specific topic that
gives you the Joy or is it about
instructing kids in a certain age group
in the topic that's really important
because if you look at the numbers you
were making 80 before you get got laid
off and then you made 50 as a cont
contractor what I'm trying to do is is
show you that you can do something you
really enjoy and make close to 80 uh
there might be some shortterm sacrifice
but I think you got to look at all your
options and I think you you've limited
your options is what I'm trying to help
you
see right yeah I understand there
there's a weird thing that Ken and I
have observed over 20 years and he have
he and I have talked about it many times
that sometimes more times than not for
some reason I don't understand the
reason people get in their heads that in
order to do something that they love it
automatically means they make
less and I don't know where this comes
from because it ought to be just the
opposite if you're doing something you
love you ought to automatically make
more because you would be enthused and
creative and motivated and everything
else but we trap ourselves into this the
only thing only way I can do something I
love is I have to um sacrifice my income
and and that's just not true uh by the
way Holden I'm a teacher yeah that's
right I teach for a living I'm probably
the best paid teacher you'll ever met me
but but I'm I'm that's what I do it's
one of my gifts it's one of my spiritual
gifts leadership and teaching and uh and
I'm very good at it I'm not good at a
lot of other things but uh but you know
I teach adults in a lot of different
formats and variations and I didn't
decide just because I love watching the
light bulb come on over someone's head
after I present them an idea and they go
I'm going to take that next step I'm
going to do that next thing a good
teacher loves that moment like you do
and I do um but I I didn't decide that
that meant I had to make less there's
another path here holding that I would
suggest to you what if you get back in
the industrial design game let's let's
let's say you get back in at 80 or let's
say that you repeat the year you had
last year and I think you should have
higher sites than 50 as a freelancer but
let's say you did 50 again as an
instructional designer how can you do
art tutoring and lessons and things like
that in an Austin Texas area where the
income would support it could you make
$330,000 or more over the next 12 months
as you begin to take that love of
instructing art and you begin to teach
some kids and some wealthy families
private lessons there's a couple ways to
get to this and I that's what Dave and I
are challenge you on is to see all of
the ways that you can make this same
income if not more and work your way
into this it's not a just All or Nothing
proposition here yeah that's exactly
right by the way the just to be very
clear the data that you're citing on the
teacher leaving oh yeah the the
classroom are not leaving the classroom
the indications are because of the
children no no it's the bureaucracy it's
the uh politics that's right and the
bureaucracy and the ridic you know
everything that every they've taken
everything away from the teacher's
ability to teach that's correct and
frustrate the crap out of them yeah and
so because they're all worried about
some kind of virtue signaling rather
than actually doing the job of teaching
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
yeah
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
we appreciate you hanging out I'm Dave
Ramsey the phone number is8
8255 225 Annie is with us in
Indianapolis hi Annie welcome to the
ramsy show hi hi what's
up um well thank you for taking my call
um so so I am just looking for advice on
how to talk to my teenage Foster son
about money in a way that isn't shameful
towards his like reality I
guess in a way that isn't what towards
his
reality like making him feel shameful
shameful oh I see Mak him feel bad yeah
okay so he's coming from a poor
environment and you don't want to make
him feel bad for that that's good that's
sweet good for you okay
um how old is
he he's 15 I can give you like an
example of something if that would help
sure okay so like for Christmas these
options are like crazy expensive things
and we're like you know we don't we
don't have the money for that we can do
this instead and um he's like well like
I know you have money and it's was like
yeah but you know we have to buy
groceries and all these things and he's
like well just wipe your food card like
well we don't have a food card and he's
talking about like Snap so like things
like that like he doesn't understand I
don't know if that makes sense yeah yeah
it does
um and how long have you been has he
been with
you um almost two months okay all right
well I
mean if he's been in and out of foster
he may be manipulating you
okay that's a possibility with that it
may not be simple ignorance it may be a
sense of I'm going to get what I can get
before they dump me back out into the
system okay so be aware of that and be
careful with that because a teenager
that's been in and out of that system
they know the plan and they know how to
work it and so uh You' you've got to be
loving and kind it's not a matter of
shaming someone but be very aware that
um he may not care about your goals or
your money he may just think I better I
you know I can get this expensive gift
and then when I'm gone I'll leave with
those tennis shoes or those that jacket
or whatever it is he's wanting okay so
that's a possibility but all that aside
we still need to try to minister to him
try to help him while he's in under your
uh care and that's so that you still got
the right question you're asking uh but
having said that then what do we do well
I I would just sit down and say Hey you
know I'm not sure if you care about this
but um but let me show you how this
stuff works
and show him a budget that this is the
money comes in and every dollar has an
assignment and we we spend some of it on
the necessities of life food shelter
clothing Transportation utilities we
spend some of it on enjoyment um and we
spend some of we invest some of it for
the future and that's what has enabled
us to be in a financial position to be
able to bring you into our home as a
foster child and feed
you and and so that we have to manage
the whole thing not just do we have the
money for that gift and and let him look
at it
holistically over your shoulder so when
our oldest one turned 12 I sat down back
in those days we did a paper budget and
I had her look at the budget with me and
and and then actually start back in
those days we wrote checks and you
remember what those were and uh but she
would write out the checks and I would
sign them and I I'll never forget uh
she's like 11 or 12 years old and she's
sweet sweet kid and she's looking at
this and she goes the
electricity is
$340 dad and I'm like yeah that's just
for one month honey she goes oh man I
see my mom's yelling at us to keep the
door closed all the time unbelievable
and turn off all the lights I now know
why she's saying that I'm like oh and so
she related it you know this this this
request for you know to behave and not
act like you're raising a barn to she
finally related it to an actual economic
thing and she went good Lord cuz this
kid probably has no idea what your
electric bill is he may not care but he
has no idea what the electric bill is
and so when he actually sees that and
you go that's why when you are staying
with us it's warm in this house because
we pay that bill and so I I would I
would introduce him to the whole picture
of
generosity of future thinking called
saving and investing of uh making sure
Necessities are taken care of before we
do Luxury things and
then uh we may not choose to buy
expensive gifts so that we can do these
other things and uh and and he might you
know go Come Away going oh that's how
rich people do it yeah and Annie I I
would recommend uh you don't commit to
this long term and because I understand
the uh the the volatility sometimes of
these situations but if I were you um I
would come up with a small amount not a
huge amount of money what what's small
give me an example uh well I don't know
their budg what do you guys make what do
you guys make income
wise uh like a year
yeah um around 85 okay let me just say
maybe you do this for two months and
take a $100 okay and I would sit down
and explain the concept of give save and
spend and living on 80% just as an
example Say Hey I want to teach you some
basic concepts and I would say here's
what we're going to do for two months
and $100 may be too much maybe it's 50
bucks okay the point is is I would I
would give that child a chance to make
some mistakes I teach them how to do it
say okay if we're going to give you 50
bucks for a month you're 15 50 bucks um
I think you should
save 10% I you should give 10% to
somebody you choose who you want to give
that to
and the rest of it is we're going to let
you just spend that how you want to with
your friends or whatever and and and
just I want you to learn how to manage
this money because longterm and then
show them based on a $330,000 salary a
$60,000 salary I would I would try to
teach with some real money knowing that
you've budgeted for it if he blows it he
blows it but he learns something through
failure I just think that's a valuable
experience for some of these kids to
realize what how quickly money gets
spent cuz let me tell you something this
kid goes out with only 50 bucks
100 Buck it's going to go quick if they
want to go to a restaurant with their
buddies uh our kids are learning that
with the money they've made Dave working
they realize how quick it is oh you want
to go to the little place with your
friends and you you you you oh yeah an
appetizer a meal oh you're broke yeah
and Annie you know I guess one other
thing because this is great such a great
question thanks for letting us go off on
it um I would tell him say you know when
I first started my adult life I didn't
have any money
and uh and so what I did though was I
started looking at what rich people do
because rich people handle money that's
how they get rich and so here's what I
learned from the rich people they always
give some they always save some and
they're always wise with they're
spending and um and then you could in
Implement what Ken's talking about in
that setting and you just teach him you
know this is this is what I learned I
learned if you if someone's doing
something well you can emulate copy what
they are doing and then you can be like
them if you want to be skinny eat what
skinny people eat right if you want a
great marriage talk to people been
married 67 years not 67 minutes and and
you know let's learn how they did that
and let's emulate successful people
that's called in business best practices
and you can tell teenagers this and they
get it um and so uh you know I want I
want to do rich people stuff with money
cuz I got a good chance of being rich
people if I do poor people's stuff with
money I got a good chance of being poor
people uh because the only reason
they're poor is not outside variables
some of it is outside variables some of
it's oppression bad systems uh bad
thinking uh there's a lot of things that
cause people be poor uh that aren't
their fault uh but some of it is
behavior and so the the only one you can
control is behavior and that's how we
meet people that used to be poor and now
are rich because they controlled the
only thing they could control which is
their
behavior and to not spend everything
they make on Friday night thank God it's
Friday you this is not a rich people
saying right and uh so they think in
tenure blocks of time not the attention
span of a gat and so these are things
you can teach him and talk to him about
and it's not about there's no shame in
any of that would never shame someone
for where they're from cuz I've been
there too but I want to want to talk
about behaviors that are going to get us
to a better place this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America so glad you are here phone
number is8 825
5225 Jordan is in Daytona Beach hi
Jordan welcome hey good afternoon guys
thank you so much thank you how can we
help um so I just got started on the
every dollar tool um I was actually out
to lunch with my manager last week he
told me about it I looked it up and
immediately signed up cool so I'm really
excited to get started on that um thank
you for for making it um so I've done
baby step one um luckily I I had you
know the the starter fund uh emergency
fund saved up already so I'm jumping
right to step two which gets scary real
fast yep um so basically uh quick quick
rundown I've got about 58,000 in
consumer debts um my question to you is
I have an old 401k it's got about
$222,000 on and I've been sitting there
for a couple years I haven't added
anything to it is it a smart move to to
close that out and use that as a jump
start on my debts okay good question
what do you
make um it's uh 60 60 to 65 that's your
household
income um yes okay all right good and
um okay and technicality to start with
you can't add to an old 401k uh you can
only roll it you can only roll it to an
IRA you can only add to a 401k where you
currently work uh and this this is an
old employer that doesn't matter but
that's a technicality the um the second
thing then is here's the thing when you
cash out a retirement account an IRA or
a 401k before 59 A5 they charge you a
10% penalty plus your tax rate your tax
rate will be probably
25% and so you're going to be hit with
35 % here and so mathematically that's
like you calling up and saying Dave I'm
really enthusi about getting out of debt
I want to borrow some money at 35%
interest oh man yeah we we wouldn't do
that we wouldn't do that so we don't
want to give the government half of this
or third of this money 78,000 bucks so
um I'm going to yeah I wish I wish it
would work but it's not a good shortcut
for that reason um people do it but when
they do it it's all emotional it's not
math the math the math the math just
screams in your face don't do it that's
exactly why I wanted your advice you
know emotionally I'm looking at it I'm
like man I could I could knock out a
huge chunk of this debt right off the
bat and get started but uh actually
about
14,000 yeah because government the
government would get s or eight and so
and roughly in where we are so that's
that's the problem uh but I think you're
going to get there and I think you're
going to get there because of what I the
way I'm hearing you
describe your first interfaces with this
uh after doing this for 30 years you've
got all the symptoms of someone who's
going to play through this you're really
going to do it and so CU you you reached
a point somewhere in the last few weeks
that you went this sucks something has
to change and I'm
it yeah exactly right yeah I mean I can
hear it in your voice and your sentence
structure it's all there so you're
you're really you're going to do this
and uh uh if you got anything that is
non-retirement that you can sell um you
know the jet ski you haven't used in two
years years or whatever um I I would do
that uh and get this jump started that
way I would do that stuff but I wouldn't
do this as far as this 401K I would jump
on ramsy solutions.com and click on
smartvestor Pro sit down and talk to a
smartvestor pro anytime you've got a
401k when you leave at a company you
ought to roll it to an IRA into good
growth stock mutual funds there's 8,000
mutual funds to pick from and uh you'll
get a better performance on that
portfolio if you learn just a little bit
about it it's really not hard to learn
about it and a smart Vestor Pro can help
you do all that and teach you so you
that that's how I would handle this good
question sir that one comes up a lot
over 30 years yeah yeah it does and and
it's smart because this guy is thinking
he's now I I love what you said you can
tell that he's tasted what the future
could look like he's like I want that
and I love that I really that's the
beauty of the every dollar app it when
you lay down your stuff on there and you
go oh crap 58,000 but oh we can do this
that's right and I can do this and I can
do this and I can do this and you start
possibility you know what does this now
make possible Right your brain starts to
work that way rather than oh God I'm
stuck life sucks you know the Biden
economy is killing me the anxiety of my
father-in-law everything I mean
everything's killing me here you know
it's just like everything isn't that
what budgeting does Dave it opens up
possibilities people realize now they're
in control yeah it gives you a sense of
it's the weirdest thing somebody can be
about to be foreclosed on and when I lay
out their budget and show them a we're
not going to get foreclosed on but B
here's not only the way to stop that but
you're going to make it all the way
around the corner and start moving
towards wealth you're not even there yet
you're only 6 hours in and your yet your
your anxiety level has dropped way down
just because you can see the future it's
called hope MH Renee is with us in
Nashville hi Renee welcome to the Ramsey
Show yes hi it's so great to talk with
you you too what's
up um
okay so this is my second time doing the
baby steps because the first time I did
not follow
instructions well that was coming
clean very you know um and uh I want to
get a bigger shovel I want to shove more
money at my debt I've already paid off
5,000 I have a total of
21,000 of credit card and personal loans
and then my mortgage and I mainly want
to pay off the
mortgage um and I just I want to do this
as quickly as possible how much is the
mortgage the mortgage is
65,000 oh great what do you
make um
60,000 about half of that is taxfree
what do you
do I I work for a pharmaceutical company
uh from home I work remote absolutely
love it it saves me so much money on gas
and food and
everything um and then the other half is
VA okay 90% disabled so that's what you
mean by the tax free income yeah
okay so when someone says they want a
bigger shovel that means I want to make
some more money bringing some more money
so based on your experience and what
you're doing now what comes to for you
if you think about the freelance uh
opportunities that are out there because
we live in an age right now where
freelance work is very of very available
so what could you do what do you bring
to the table as a skill set that you
could start to look for freelance
opportunities or even a better full-time
job well um I have a lot of friends that
do do that do door Dash um some of them
has been a blessing and very lucrative
for them others it's not so much um
that's not a skill set I can drive a car
I wouldn't call that a skill in fact my
wife doesn't think I'm a very good
driver for being honest so what what are
your what are your skill sets that that
you know okay can I'm I'm good at uh
organizational things or I'm a project
manager that's what I'm asking you
because that's where your opportunity is
to make more
money okay I'm I'm good at my job I'm
good at processing medication great
that's where I'd be looking I mean
listen if you could go for from working
at home to full-time or taking on
another work from home job that's where
you need to be looking right now what's
available in my space where I know I
have the qualifications I don't have to
learn anything I just have to say I'm
willing and I can come in and make a
difference that's where you start
because that's where we double our
income potentially uh if you can't
double it anything else right now is
extra that's what you need to be doing
Dave when you're thinking bigger shovel
yep that's right and it may involve
stepping outside of some of your comfort
zone very few things of growth happen
inside the comfort zone and so it may
involve that you do something that's a
little bit uncomfortable in order to
have the comfort of being completely
debt-free so I mean if you found
$100,000 extra money in the next 3 years
you wouldn't even have a
mortgage that would be very
cool I'd be willing to be uncomfortable
for a couple of years to do that ooh
this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
oh
our scripture today 1 Corinthians 13:6
and 7 love does not Delight in evil but
rejoices with the truth it always
protects always trusts always hopes
always
perseveres Dr Martin Luther King said
change does not roll in on the wheels of
inevitability but comes through
continuous struggle wow that works in
the baby steps right there works
everywhere everywh we honor him today on
MLK day wow absolutely
incredible uh all right Cody is with us
Cody is in Indianapolis hi Cody welcome
to the ramsy show oh thank you for
taking my call sure what's up so I've
been listening to your show since about
2020 and I paid off my debt except for
my mortgage and found a way to go to
college debt free nice through Star
College achievement program and I got my
degree in corporate accounting good for
you when I when I graduated I started
working for an accounting firm in tax
and bookkeeping and I found myself
hating every morning to have to get up
and go to work so my wife and I decided
that how did you go through all that
trouble to become an accountant and not
realize you hated
accounting it was um more about the
leadership and not oh so it's not you
hated accounting you hated that company
yes oh okay all right I'm back with you
okay so you left I hope decided yes I
did I quit and decided I'm going to
finish my CPA license and give myself
some Focus but I just also needed to get
out of the house so I got a job as a
baker while I was work um while I was
training with the owner as the baker uh
we talked about my work history of being
a manager of restaurants and coffee
shops and my work in accounting and she
asked me to take on more of a business
development role and so now I truly love
what I do but I find myself constantly
thinking about work and doing things all
day long at all hours of the day with
the um with the work what does a baker
need with business development yeah
that's my question as well what are you
developing well I she owns a series of
restaurants and I am helping her to try
and grow her
business what does that mean I we have a
goal of increasing Revenue this year and
so she wants to use my skills and do
that with
and the that's not business development
that's
marketing business development is where
you bring in investors or or you bring
in outside money of some kind I mean
developing the business by adding
revenue is just marketing you're trying
to get more customers right well I'm
doing uh bookkeeping I'm writing
standard operating procedures and I'm
trying to I'm working on developing new
products for a bakery so that means we
got to sell more bread more cakes more
muffins right she owns a series of
restaurants right yeah okay it's more
than just the bakery it's not just the
bakery that's where I started but that's
not where I'm okay I'm sorry all
right so you're you're that sounds
almost like a COO like you're doing
operations and accounting okay so all
right so you're CFO coo combo right now
you're doing bookkeeping and looking at
the finances and looking at the
operations
systems yes that's correct all right I'm
with you okay and you all you all named
that business development okay now I'm
I'm caught up so what's your question
then so I love what I do but I feel like
I am doing a lot more than what I'm
being paid at when I was making $16 an
hour I was you know just in the bakery I
could clock in clock out and it was off
my mind and now I'm working all the time
or what feels like all the time and
doing a lot more intensive work than I
was before you should pay you $16 an
hour still yes and so I wanted to ask
how do I
negotiate how to negotiate compensation
for that and how long has that been
going
on uh I've just gotten into this role
about a month ago oh okay but we've set
some goals and so why did you all not
talk about compensation when we talked
about changing your complete job
description that is uh why I'm calling
now I realized that it is a
communication thing and think that it I
just need to know how to go about all
right so how many restaurants let me try
to break this down for you how many
restaurants does she
own uh two with a third one being open
okay so what you've got to do is you got
to do your homework you're a numbers guy
and I would start with you know uh the
the revenue I'd find out or she'll tell
you certainly what your is yeah I that's
fair that's true you're in the books
thank you Dave uh but Grace on the gross
revenues of restaurants like that and
someone who's operating like a general
manager or a no coo for somebody who
owns two restaurants so i' I'd be
looking at what that is paying uh out
there in the marketplace you've got to
start with a Baseline and I can tell you
it's not $16 an hour so you got to start
with some real research that is easy to
figure out for the whole package right
now uh just over a million okay all
right so what does a Co make for a
company that's grossing a million
dollars a year yeah it ain't
$16 all right yeah so let's look that up
and then go hey I looked at this and
this is what it appears you know I found
these three different restaurant
companies that are doing about a million
and they're paying a COO or CFO this
kind of a thing it appears I'm doing
those types of jobs here if that's not
what you think I'm doing then let's talk
about it but if if I am doing that then
um then this is the market rate for that
how do you feel about
that okay one thing I'd pull out of the
conversation is just because you're
thinking about it all the time and you
want to put all this work in that
doesn't mean that you know that that
plays into your compensation package too
I know you're excited about it but also
understand that you know this
compensation you're looking at is is
based on you not thinking about it every
second of the day if you want to think
about it every second of the day that's
on you but make sure you don't kind of
fall into that well I'm thinking about
it all the time and I'm working 60 hours
if she's not asking you to work 60 hours
uh my point is is is is is be be
levelheaded about that you're you can
care deeply about something and still go
home and have dinner with your wife and
turn it off right I mean that's I I do
and I own and run this place for 30
years that's right so I mean um and it's
a little more than a million Topline so
I mean I I turn it off at night I don't
think anything about it on Sunday when
I'm in church I'm not sitting and
thinking about you know the payroll here
or something I'm I'm just not you the
thing Dave I wanted to get you nor have
I ever yeah right and and here's the
thing he was talking about you know
listen I was on my way to being a CPA
he's still doing that and then he gets
this opportunity the bakery situation
was just a stop Gap really proud of him
for that but you get an opportunity like
this and it may not be the greatest
opportunity I think it's exciting to him
but I'd also in this advice we've given
him to go wait a second uh do where am I
at on this whole CPA path and I was
heading a distraction I wonder it's
exciting it's a challenge guy who's
challenged by this and I get it but is
it the right path yeah you don't want to
you don't want to end up in something by
default yeah you want you want to end up
in in something because of
intentionality and you you are in this
by default doesn't necessarily mean it's
bad but um but it does give us both a
reason to give you pause to say Hey you
had a path MH and bread baking threw you
off of it that's exactly right and so uh
you know do you want to do you want to
do this and are you intentionally going
to turn down a different road than you
were on before that's okay I mean Yogi
Bear said when you come to a fork in the
road take it right so yes great call
well one of the lessons here we all have
to learn Cody is is that we all desire
to be wanted and when somebody comes to
us and says hey I know you're baking for
me you're doing a good job but uh the
fact that you got this degree in this
and this you could do this for me and
there's something to that to be valued
and to be wanted and that can be a
distraction and sometimes saying yes to
something good is the enemy to this idea
that we had that was great for us and
that's why I'm asking just consider it
yeah one of the systems you need to put
in place is don't move any more
employees to new positions without
compensation packages there is that I am
concerned that it didn't come up at all
from a leadership Ste from neither one
of you yeah neither one of you thought
you you know we're going to talk about
the fact that I make $16 an hour and I'm
going to run your business from the
inside I don't think so I should come up
it should come up early in the
conversation you know wow
Ken Coleman good show today thank you
sir that puts us hour of the Ramsey Show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
[Applause]
[Music]
Jesus
yeah